hey guys it's inka and in this video i
will only be making and eating foods
from studio ghibli films
for 24 hours since i did the disney
princess cooking challenge from last
time i have read all your comments and
received a lot of amazing follow-up
requests
but this is one of those that got me
really excited because
i love studio ghibli films i grew up
with them
i even worked at a store that sold
studio ghibli products it's so
incredible how they are able to build
these
magical worlds from scratch also the
food in every single film of theirs
just looks incredible maybe it's just
something to do with anime food they
always look even better
than they do in real life because
there's so many films to choose from
i am going to try and pack in as much as
i can within these 24 hours
i am truly very looking forward to this
because this is something that i've been
wanting to do for such a long time and
now i get to do it with you guys so
with that being said let's get to the
kitchen
and start cooking good morning everyone
it is the beginning of a brand new day
and i am so pumped
to test out all these new recipes and
also really looking forward to being
able to eat all of them i feel like for
breakfast the most
classic one that we immediately think of
is the one from how's moving castle
thick strips of bacon
and eggs but because i feel like it's a
dish that has also been done
so many times already what i'm gonna be
making instead is the ramen
from ponyo i actually grew up eating
ramen for breakfast is
fairly popular in hong kong so to me it
kind of makes sense
just that i might be treating myself a
little bit so with that being said
let me show you guys the ingredients i
have there's only four ingredients
required for this ramen the most
important thing is this ramen the reason
i bought this one specifically
is that it actually doesn't require
cooking over the stove top all you
really need to do
is pour hot water and then cover it with
a lid and wait for three minutes that's
actually exactly what they did in ponyo
remember how the mom came in
she poured like hot water so we'll be
able to recreate that scene almost
exactly ramen aside there's also some
scallions as
garnish as well as a hard-boiled egg and
some ham which ponyo was obsessed with
so i had to make sure
i got some good ham so i think breakfast
will be pretty straightforward i'm gonna
cook the egg really quick chop up my
scallions
slice the ham and then we can get the
ramen going my egg has been boiled
it's all peeled now so we're going to
slice it in half nice
i have all my ingredients ready it is
time to cook the ramen
this is what the ramen looks like on the
inside you can see that it's already
been flavored there's no
extra broth packets so i'm just going to
go ahead and put all this in here
instructions say to put 400 milliliters
of water
and then we're just gonna cover it up my
bowl didn't come with a lid so i'm just
using my pot lid but i'm setting it now
for three minutes on my phone
and i'll probably add the rest of the
toppings around
two and a half minutes in
it is done tada i love how this looks
and the noodles
are definitely cooked it also just
smells really good
i can totally see why ponyo would love
this also before i start digging in i'm
just gonna make a quick drink because i
remember in the film the mom made this
honey drink for both of them
and look at that i just remember this
scene being
so satisfying in the movie pretty much
just adding some honey to
a little bit of milk and hot water
on a cold winter night this is perfect
now let me dig into the ramen
you can see that the noodles are a
little flatter oh i should also try the
broth
broth is also really good it's very much
just like chicken soup with i think some
soy sauce the texture of this noodle is
also i think more similar to that of
cup noodles which is probably why it
cooks so fast i'm almost gonna have a
piece of ham
ponyo when she saw this she was like
yeah this is for ponyo
as you guys can see just like in the
film this meal is so so straightforward
everybody when we think of ponyo now we
think of this bowl of ramen exactly and
it really is
as comforting as it looks so i'm gonna
finish the rest of this now
before we move on to the next meal it is
lunch time and i am ready
to make some more food and eat again so
for this meal
i am thinking of making the bento box
from
totoro i remember being amazed by just
how much the older sister satsuki could
cook she was still just a kid but she
was making these
amazing meals for her family and also
these beautiful bento boxes so yeah i
thought i would give it a try
i love making bento boxes normally i
once made
a really really cute one i do have a
bento box here
i'll be packing lunch in this tiny
little box let me show you guys the
ingredients i have so again for this
meal there aren't that many ingredients
some edamame beans and then i have some
fish here i believe they're called
kaplan or capelin i know my grandma
actually just grills these
and eats them with a little bit of salt
so that's probably what i'm gonna do
with that
some umebashi which is just pickled
plums this i know is very
very common in japanese cuisine people
generally enjoy this with rice which is
what we'll be doing today and then for
the pink portion i have these salmon
flakes
i believe in the film they actually used
another ingredient
sakura dembu which i actually used in my
pink foods cooking challenge before it's
basically this like
seasoned cod fish condiment but since i
couldn't find it this time
i'm going with this instead and then of
course over here
i have my beautiful rice based on what
we see of the ingredients this is
actually
a fairly traditional japanese bento box
so i
am excited to put it together because i
don't have a grill at home
i am just going to cook the fish over
the stove top i'm going to add some salt
and i'm going to let it slowly cook in
the meantime
i'm going to open this this is pretty
much already cooked i just need to
microwave them a little bit
[Music]
i have all my ingredients ready to go
now for my favorite part
assembling the bento box first up is the
rice
and there's gonna be a lot of it making
bento boxes
is one of the most therapeutic things
lay our fish right on
there fish flakes it's a very fishy
bento
and then the peas last but not least
just have a plum
there we go tada that's kind of what it
looks like what do you think isn't this
just so cute really packed with
protein there's a lot of rice if i just
packed it up
this is my little bento box i would
totally take this
to work i love this so much there's like
a considerable amount of weight
in this because of all the rice just the
idea of having somebody pack you a lunch
like this no wonder the younger sister
was so excited
i would be excited if somebody made me
this i'm going to dig in
so this is the fish there's a lot of
like
roll on this side
definitely reminds me of my grandma's
cooking she can eat like 10 of these in
one meal the fish smell is definitely
strong
but i like it and it's perfectly salty
so we can eat a good
big bite of rice i actually eat this a
lot
normally just salmon flakes with rice i
knew going in there that was going to be
great i'm going to try this pickled plum
it has a very very strong flavor that's
like both sweet and savory with like
kind of sourness to it it's meant to be
eaten with rice because
of the like amount of flavor it packs
into one bite
this is very very enjoyable it's so well
balanced and it's so convenient for
those of you who haven't tried making a
bento box before though you should
definitely
give it a shot another meal down time
for me to do some more work before we
need some more food i guess so it hasn't
been that long after lunch it's still
fairly early in the day
i just uploaded a cut of my video i'm
just waiting for
notes and i'm craving something sweet so
i think
now is a good time to take a mini break
i don't know how many of you actually
recognize the character here but this is
setsuko
the little girl from grave of the
fireflies great for the fireflies
is my most favorite studio ghibli film
it is
also probably the most depressing every
time i watch it i cry this candy is
known as sakuma drops they're these hard
candies
that are made with real fruit juice this
was satsuko's favorite thing
every time she was sad or upset or tired
her brother would give her one of these
and i think for me because of how young
i was when i first watched the film
i've always had a fondness for this it
actually says since
1908 and i know for as long as i've been
here too that this packaging has stayed
the same this is super nostalgic for me
so this is what it looks like
it's like the flavors that we see on
here already it smells kind of fruity
it's definitely very sweet but i feel
like you do get a lot more of those
natural
fruit flavors all right i'm gonna
continue working out but i'm glad to
have
this by my side it is not quite dinner
time yet
it's actually i think around like 4 p.m
ish
but i thought i would pop into the
kitchen for
a snack honestly usually for snacks i
just grab something light like saltine
crackers
or fruits but today i am in for a treat
because i have
the steamed buns from spirited away in
the film
i believe chihiro gets these from her
friends they're just like these
giant steamed buns that i guess is very
popular in the bath house
i actually just went ahead and made my
own i have my own steamed bun recipe
that i shared a while ago and then i
bought some red bean paste
and essentially what i did was wrap a
big chunk of dough around
an equally big chunk of red bean paste
and then i went ahead and steamed it and
that's what brings me
to today where i have this giant
bun i have never made steamed bun this
big the red bean is actually showing
because of
how much i tried to cram in there but
you do get the fluffiness still i don't
actually think i will be able to finish
this if i want to have dinner but i'm
going to go ahead and take
a big bite it was so satisfying seeing
her bite into it this is probably a meal
in itself
look at how much red bean i try to cram
in there that's why it's like coming out
it is
very very good so i think i'm probably
actually just going to take a few more
bites and then save the rest of this for
tomorrow because it
is a lot it is also very
satisfying to hold upon this big work
hours are now
officially over and that means i am
ready to make some dinner there were so
many dishes to choose from but i decided
to go with this one
salmon dish from porko russo this dish
actually appears in the beginning of the
film when porco visits the hotel that is
run by his friend gina
treats himself to this nice fancy dinner
the dish seems relatively simple the
salmon is served with this sort of
creamy white sauce i'm going to be
making a burblok sauce which is
essentially a fancy french butter sauce
even though
the film is set in italy i just assume
that because it's such like a
nice setting that the sauce is probably
also elevated so
let's take a look at the ingredients
some salmon which i am going to
cook in the oven a lot of butter
shallots some baby carrots
and then of course i have some white
wine which is to go with
the sauce and of course the white wine
is also here for us to enjoy with our
dinner later so i'm going to start with
the sauce and begin with cutting up the
shells
got my saucepan put all this right in
add in my
wine now i'm just going to turn it on to
high heat and let it cook
down until we only have around two
tablespoons left
prep my salmon so i can pop that in the
oven
[Music]
this has been reduced by a lot you guys
can see that there's barely any liquid
left i am going to
turn the heat to low and just one by one
put this butter in
my sauce is pretty much done i am going
to strain it
and season it with a little bit of salt
and pepper now is a good time for me to
pop the salmon in the oven
as well as cook my carrots
pretty much after that i will be ready
to plate things up all right
here we go starting off with my salmon
and my sauce
trying to match the photo now for the
carrots
which admittedly are not my favorite
things
and there we go this is the porko russo
salmon i guess there's not too much
going on but
i'm excited to eat it and i do want to
recreate that scene of him cutting into
it
this dish is a lot simpler than most of
the other ones but it is at the same
time supposed to be the fanciest so i
am going to be enjoying this with a
glass of white wine
similar to what porkal did okay you know
what he had a whole bottle of wine i'm
gonna go get the whole bottle i'm gonna
put my wine right here off to the side
and
dig into this meal
i know the burblamp sauce doesn't look
like much but it actually goes really
well the salmon not surprisingly it's
very very creamy very very rich
if you're ready for the sheer amount of
butter that also goes into it it's very
good though i feel like if i played some
jazz music in the background
maybe had a sip of my wine this could be
me at a hotel somewhere
in italy having a meal by myself dinner
was a pretty simple affair
but don't you worry because i have an
extremely indulgent dessert coming up
soon
so hang in there with me i'm gonna
finish my dinner
and then we can probably pretty soon
get to dessert it's probably only been
an hour after dinner or so
but it is time for what is probably
my favorite meal of the day for dessert
today i have decided to go
all out and recreate the cake from
kiki's delivery service kiki actually
gets this as a surprise gift from one of
her customers this like really kind
old lady who i think wanted to wish her
happy birthday so in my head i was
immediately like this has to be the best
chocolate cake ever
so i actually started preparing for this
cake two days ago
i actually followed a tasty recipe
that's called
the best chocolate cake which i thought
was pretty appropriate it does involve
some pretty interesting ingredients like
mayo
and stout but i made sure to use the
best chocolate i could find
and what i ended up with was this super
rich
super chocolatey cake that wasn't too
sweet and it's just
very very dense and then once my cake
was done i let it cool a little bit
and then divided it up into three layers
and i also made this
again a super decadent super rich
chocolate buttercream frosting
that i kind of sandwiched into the
middle to create those beautiful layers
and then covered it
up completely this frosting truly is one
of the most
luxurious i have ever made and after
that
i made my chocolate ganache frosting
which really was just some semi-sweet
chocolate some bittersweet chocolate
some whipping cream and a little bit of
corn syrup because i really wanted it to
be shiny just like it looked in the film
and then i just poured that all over my
cake earlier today and oh my god it
looked so good already
i was so tempted to eat it then but of
course i couldn't forget about the
decorations which i decided to make
using fondant i haven't really worked
with fondant before but what i
essentially tried to do was to sketch
out each letter
and drawing onto like parchment paper
which i then
cut up this process was super tedious i
probably did not have the right tools to
do most of this
but i tried my best and yeah
this is what i ended up with so it's
been a super long journey this cake
really has
taken a lot of time and effort but that
brings me to
today where i have my beautiful cake
oh my god it's so heavy it's definitely
on the shinier side and then i also have
my little fondant cutouts that i
made earlier today so what i'm gonna do
now is very carefully
transfer it onto the cake
and try not to mess up this is what's
going to make
our beautiful chocolate cake the kiki's
delivery service cake
this is my picture reference i just have
this on the side
put my ribbon back in my tree all right
and then my letters
okay last one
it is done this is what my cake looks
like i am freaking out because i really
thought i was going to like
mess up really bad on this last step but
looking at it now
look at it from this angle it almost
looks exactly like the one in the film
so happy oh my goodness i am so pleased
i really don't think i've made a dessert
better than this
like ever in my entire life this has
really been quite the project i feel
like a proud
mom i just gave birth to a cake it is
time for me to cut into this
and enjoy my dessert i have also been
wanting to eat this for a long time
all right let's let's cut up a slice
goodbye kiki
i'm treating myself today wow
can you see the insides this is my cake
it's so much cake but
i love how this came out take a big bite
right now
cheers to finishing this challenge let
me take a bite
this cake is incredible there's so many
flavors going on the chocolate cake base
in itself was already
so rich and so dense and then there was
the chocolate buttercream frosting
another chocolate ganache frosting which
just feels like i'm eating truffles and
cake at the same time
this meal is the best meal i have ever
created on
any of the challenges this concludes my
24 hour studio ghibli meals only
challenge
it has been such a great time but i
think the best part of this really was
being able to bring all these amazing
anime foods
into real life and i hope i did okay i
would love to know what you guys think
and also what other challenges should i
try
on that note i will see you guys next
time while i finish up my cake bye